wenn so ein punkt machte darf ich ein
tweet auf lukas account schreiben und
damit wir richtig gemein auf jeden fall
los gehts und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge kräftiger heute
spielen wir gegen psv jung ich bin
orange ich bin jetzt 28 38 jungen von
mir dreimaliger weltmeister 1974 steht
nein da kommst du nicht raus den
städtischen winterdienst unterbrochen
ein paar löcher sollte man sich drüber
springen müssen
als abschluss gegen luke ein köpfige
verliere das gibt es nicht ich habe
überhaupt kein land
wir haben überhaupt keine power ups an
merke ich gerade kann ich noch machen
wir sagen ja verlierer muss der für die
eines verlieren gleich sein easy
verlierer muss einen speed beim eintritt
bei anderen das machen wir halt heimat
nach was riskant ist nein ja wohl sehr
schön und ich hätte ich es kann
irgendwie sind gleich fünf mehr als fünf
oder gleichviel
falls nicht gerade wieder doch jetzt
regelt wo junge da ich jetzt ist in
massakrieren können wetzlar rasch
nein doch jetzt habe ich ein problem ist
wie ein ganz großes problem
das ist es wird nicht akzeptiert
wieviel war ich am anfang 4 1 oder 4 1
das richtig aufgeholt
dann hat es geholt was ich kann das
nicht ganz genau wie man nicht an die
valora in gott euch darum gekommen
sechs junge komm schon jetzt geht hier
gerade um einen später dann in jeder
zweite spiel auch noch das war ja vor
allem da oben also eine lücke in der
anlage wie kann das denn sein
da hab ich den skill ausgepackt doch
übertreibt das war richtig ist kann man
noch ein punkt da hab ich das ding
gewonnen
ich habe ja gesagt mit dem 23 das hab
ich gesagt als ich gefragt
nein machen 2001 diesen zehn minuten
aber das ist das ist jetzt mit power ups
ich habe das erste ding schon gewonnen
du musst deinen einsatz bringen ich habe
vorhin gesagt wir machen das beste aus
zwei spielen das habe ich gesagt ja das
habe ich das habe ich gesagt als ich
vorne lag es geht hier gerade um einen
tweet oder
oder wie blogger machen danach wieder
gleichstand und lutz
junge ist jetzt eigentlich sehr
aufholjagd und das mit lücke in der
lücke kommt die 2000 jahre später weiß
sobald ich sobald ich neun punkte haben
in diesem spiel muss darf ich schon
schreiben eingestimmt wir können zu
schaffen
nach 1 10 zu 8 für mich nie wahrer als
was macht das hier macht das hier und
ich krieg gerade auch die schildkröten
kann die kurve noch kratzen der leute
noch zwei und damit den trieb schreiben
junge das ist eine richtig geile
challenge spitzen gedanke pilot von
manga wir jetzt klingt so leute wo leute
das wird eine fette beute jetzt auch die
schildkröte
danke okay das war scheiße jung
okay wir jetzt auch noch wissen was
gemacht da oben angekommen 3.7 alter bei
mir gerade eltern ein du darfst nicht
wenn du die acht erreicht ist ich kann
nur noch gewinnen wir jetzt drei punkte
am stück mache ja ja nein
aber was erwartest du kannst auch
unentschieden kannst du denn jean mach
ja unentschieden wird verloren aber
leute wenn ich jetzt noch einen punkt
machen wenn jetzt noch einen punkt
machen
da hab ich ein tweet auf lukas account
schreiben und damit wir richtig gemeinde
auf jeden fall schlechte
ausgangssituation
ich komme nicht aus
nein ich konnte niemals raus
ich muss zwei hintereinander gewinnt mit
92 punkten vorsprung gewinnen warum bin
ich so schnell ich so gut nicht so gut
nicht so gut
ja ich habe gewonnen jawohl ich hätte
noch gewinnen können
ich hatte immer noch gewinnen ich muss
nicht die differenz also was ist machen
wir dann so ein auswärtstor regelung
heißt ist dann 12 zu 10 also wir gehen
wir gehen nicht danach und sagen ja der
hat mehr punkte weil das mit der keinen
sinn ergeben
online als auch aber wenn ich es will
kann es ist alles ganz ohne
entschädigung wird das gerade warum das
hätte ich auch nicht gedacht ich hab
mich ja dann darfst du zehn zu acht
geworden und ich 12 10
aber sagt man wenn wir mehr punkte
kassiert hat es ist schlecht oder
einfach unentschieden
oh ja hier niemals die machst du nicht
das kann ich sein kann nicht sein
ich muss ich da macht das lieber weiter
was machst du da das gemeint niemals
junges jawohl es hier ja wohl ja wohl
zwei punkte in der folge dass man konnte
das ist wie so viele elfmeter schießen
wurde nach der tat so was macht es hier
matthias machnig mit bratwurst ist hier
sehr schön und damit hole ich mir den
punkt wunderbar nein nein nein stoff
jetzt stimmt doch einfach wie kommt er
raus
wie konnte das uns drei tage später
vollkommen jawohl junge
wir wollten eigentlich was für meinen
kanal ausnehmen ich kann einfach fitter
das ist jetzt nicht wirklich war
das ist jetzt echt hat nicht wahr nein
nein nein nein kommt lang da komme ich
langsam jammern ja junge wie habe ich da
die führung geholt du kannst noch so
viele punkte und zeit rausfinden können
erhält der schwede matchball
jetzt jetzt hole ich mir genau jetzt
dsds junge 100 sprachen die ganze zeit
über leute statt man die kommentare
welchen trick ihr bei luca schreiben
würde wenn ihr die gelegenheit hätte
lucas verlinkt wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder haut rein macht's
gut und lassen daumen nach oben dafür
mehr pc